well my friends inflation is down
significantly and Joe Biden's approval
rating continues to climb in a horrible
turn of events for the right which wants
to continue to tell the lie that
democratic presidents are terrible for
the economy now you all know that I
don't actually play these games when it
comes to the economy you all know that
when we talk like this it's sort of
tongue-in-cheek because the reality is
that on many of these issues presidents
have very little influence one way or
the other I don't play the gas prices
game I will jokingly say how did Joe
Biden get gas prices to be down a dollar
seventy per gallon as they are
but of course I don't really give them
credit for that the same way that I
don't blame him for the fact that gas
prices went up but for the right Wingers
that see the world in this way we should
be aware of what is going on and as I'm
I'm an idiot when it comes to this stuff
but I predicted we would get down into
the sixes in the first part of 2023 and
inflation would probably be down into
the four fives by the middle or third
quarter of 2023 and we continue to go in
that direction no we learned this
morning CNBC report consumer prices fell
0.1 percent in December in line with
expectations
excluding food and energy core CPI row
0.3 percent on an annual basis headline
CPI meaning Top Line inflation is now up
6.5 percent while core inflation is up
5.7 percent the biggest reason for the
easing in inflation came from a sharp
drop in gasoline clean prices which are
now lower on a year-over-year basis I
want to tell everybody again because
people are so confused and they write to
me things that make no sense when we
talk about 6.5 percent
what we're talking about is over the
last year so we just got the December
number so when we now say year over year
we're talking about price increase from
December 2021 to December 2022. every
month you shift by one month what is the
12-month period we're talking about so
in December when we got the November
number we were talking about inflation
from November 21 to November 22.
it's now January we've now added the
December 22 inflation data and removed
the November 21 so we've changed the
range instead of November 21 to November
22 we're now talking about December 21
to December 22. that inflation number is
down from being in the eights to 6.5
percent that is what we are talking
about when we talk about inflation this
is now six months in a row that
inflation has come down
core inflation from October to December
was only 3.1 percent annualized that's
the lowest such reading in 15 months gas
as I mentioned is down a dollar seventy
per gallon from its peak food inflation
is slowing last month we saw actually
the smallest increase in food prices in
almost two years the cost of goods is
falling for electronics used car prices
have come down which got completely out
of control wages are higher now than six
months ago so it's not prices are coming
down and so are wages wages are still
higher prices are lower when you adjust
everything for inflation we have the
lowest unemployment rate in 50 years and
it is at least partially being perceived
by voters
as Joe Biden being a generally good
Steward of the economy you don't have to
believe as I don't believe that every
one of these numbers is related to who's
President I didn't believe it under
Trump and I don't believe it's the case
under Biden I'm not playing games with
that but when you see the zoomed out
version of what's happening in the
country you see a pretty steady uptrend
in Joe Biden's approval which bottomed
out in Late July
and as you if you're looking on the
screen it's been up up up and there's a
new little uptick here even in the last
week where Joe Biden's approval is now
up to 44 now you might say 44 that's
terrible
um yeah I mean listen the the point here
is
in the modern
hyper polarized climate of American
politics you look at Bush Obama and
Trump approvals over time
44 at this point in one's term is
actually just fine it's uncontroversial
is the point the idea that the country
is furious and disgusted with Joe Biden
it's just not borne out in the data so
skip the David you're a democratic chill
stuff I've never been a registered
Democrat I don't care about Joe Biden I
don't care about the Democratic party
what I'm coming to you and saying is the
American people are realizing that what
Republicans are offering is nonsense if
you look at the Republican priorities
that have been made clear
since they took over the House of
Representatives very recently their
ideas benefit the super wealthy they
want to
essentially help the wealthy avoid taxes
at the expense of ordinary middle class
taxpayers House Republicans introduced a
bill to block actions that would lower
gas prices they gutted a bunch of Ethics
requirements they are pushing a bill
that would actually increase tax rates
on middle class families at the net
effective level and they're open to open
to cuts to Social Security and Medicare
that's what Republicans are offering now
hopefully they won't get any of it done
because the Republicans don't control
the Senate but inflation numbers
improving very good economic numbers you
see what Republicans are offering it
makes sense that Joe Biden's approval
keeps ticking up and quite frankly
18 months ago yeah 12 months ago roughly
um I would not have said Joe Biden is
well positioned for re-election in 2024.
right now I think Joe Biden is
dramatically better positioned for
re-election doesn't mean he is running
or should run or shouldn't run but just
based on the data the economy is quite
strong and that tends to um bode well
when presidents argue for their own
re-election
one of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping